all right reject nation well we already
put up our quick thoughts on YouTube you
might have already caught it but today
we're gonna do our official movie review
of tomb raiders two things before we go
into this it's a couple of thank-yous
first thank you would have to be to my
brother
jab Iike way from the get Jabby YouTube
channel he helped get us into the
screening he's the only reason we got
into an early screening so thank you so
much my literal brother you can go check
out his movie review on his channel that
is get Jabby and second thing is we want
to give a shout out and a big thank you
to today's video sponsor we've loved
working with viewer reviews.com viewer
reviews is a new social platform that
determines how well you will like a
movie based on your taste in the films
you reviewed on the site your reviews
also helps you to connect with people
who share your passion and taste for
movies think of it like a more
personalized Rotten Tomatoes tailored
directly to your and your friends
cinematic taste we just started using
viewer reviews and the matches are
pretty spot-on real easy to get started
once you create an account you'll fill
out a couple basic questionnaires to
give the site a sense for your specific
taste and from there you're ready to
start reviewing movies sharing your
tasting connecting with people so hit
that link down in the description box
people and check out viewer reviews.com
today and don't forget to follow the
real rejects breweries have been very
kind to us so thank you for sponsoring
this video and we're starting to post
written reviews so you know in case
you're interested in that let's do our
actual movie review now reasons to see
and reasons not to see term
reason to see number one definitely
Alicia vikander as Laura the Croft okay
if there's one thing you got to give
this movie even if you don't like the
movie as a whole if you don't like the
plot or whatever Alicia vikander
kills it in this movie madman from a
physical standpoint yes she is ripped
like nobody's business manic that her
first scene not like I was mad and she's
this really emotional character but
beyond being like emotional deep and
heavy it's the lighter moments of her
character that I really appreciated
moments of conversation moments of just
talking or chatting where you see this
is a fully three-dimensional character I
felt like I was just watching a human
being in Iraq with people or being put
in strenuous situations throughout the
whole film she can plausibly kick an ass
but she's plausibly vulnerable and the
movie takes time to relish in her
performance I mean it's not necessarily
a character study but each major
challenge this movie presents her with
not only does she rise to that but you
also get to see in alicia vikander's
performance the effect it's having on
her the impact and that's just details
that we don't often get especially in
movies like these and in a lot of just
standard action movies we don't get
those I watched all the cutscenes for
the Tomb Raider game that this movie is
mainly inspired from in terms of video
game character bringing to real life she
totally reminds me of Laura Croft from
the video game I love all the details to
the action sequences of this woman who
struggles who a woman who has to learn
and adapt and be resourceful exactly you
do see her at a starting point where she
has to grow if you're gonna compare to
the Angelina Jolie version where she's
just badass and ready to kill whatever
moment and she could handle had anything
into like the finale that's not this
character from the very beginning you're
like oh this this woman has some things
to learn she has to get stronger
emotionally physically mentally damn is
she pull off a great arc in this film I
thought she's perfect in this movie yeah
and she's also perfectly her father's
daughter without it being the
explanation for how she was able to do
everything like totally easy like you
get where she derives her spunk in her
spirit from but she's still gotta work
at it and Alicia vikander kills it
reason the scene number two the
supporting cast the supporting cast is
really good in this film no one really
shines as much as Alicia vikander does
in order they have to they're the
supporting cast and the main character
Laura Croft is the one they have to
really nail down but in terms of
material that's been given to the actors
the written just decently enough the
cast they do elevate the material
they've been given Walton Goggins as the
main villain Mathias in this film a very
different approach than the cliche
villain were used to it's very different
from the video game Mathias but in terms
of a movie and what they do with a film
they could have easily made this some
cliche bad dude
you could have made a Bobby Cannavale
Ian Jumana yeah but instead they gave
him a character here that has a real
motivation has some real emotional death
the other character in there Dominic
West as Richard Croft he's not really
shown in the trailers and that's for a
good reason so I don't
say too much but his performance could
have easily just been another cliched
character and while there's cliche
things to be had with his character
Dominic West brings a level of life to
it and more importantly the
father/daughter relationship incredibly
believable in this film one of the
biggest standouts for me is Daniel Wu as
Liu Ren I really liked the little bond
that he forms with Lara and the way they
play off each other and as you pointed
out the fact that this movie doesn't
feel the need to make it a love interest
thing like they're able to just work
together and I believe their rapport
back and forth of a lot and that's
another character that could have easily
been brushed to the side but they
decided to do something with them and
elevate him and make it more meaningful
without doing too much the retirement of
like are we gonna get a more focus oh we
doing okay perfect that's like the right
amount that's no I need it from the guy
it's like the writing is enough to make
these more than nothing characters and
then the rest the actors do a really
fine job for the most part of filling in
the blanks and making them feel real and
making them feel nuanced you know the
performances really do help this film a
lot I think reason to see number three
some pretty damn good action sequences
okay so there's gonna be a couple of let
me clarify here with the action
sequences because there's a variety of
action sequences a lot of good on foot
sequences a lot of great moments that
really honor the game in terms of having
to get out of a real perilous situation
and she has a lot of the grunting and
struggling there's some real type of
fighting that if there was just some
blood this movie would have been r-rated
so where there's a couple months where
people were like oh like in a pg-13
movie that's really hard to get a
reaction like that well a lot of the
action sequences to enhance the struggle
and the stakes they take time to build
character beats around the action and
one thing I appreciated is that coming
out of a video game there is a variety
to the action sequences so you have one
that feels like oh here's what might
have been your sneaking mission in a
game or here's your puzzle yeah like
that airplane sequence is you know sees
in the trailer yeah her versus the
elements there's a lot of variety and
for the most part captured in a way that
accentuates it I saw this on one Rotten
Tomatoes capsule before we start doing
this review one thing this and they said
it was like the action scenes like
tension and I wouldn't agree with that
actually on things I wouldn't want to
take away I had for me there's something
to be said about certain action
sequences for a lot of them I was
definitely like no this is a pretty
intense
there's suspense too some of these
scenes yeah even if every one of them
isn't necessary and even if some of them
perhaps go on a little long I feel like
nothing was put there just frivolous
yeah you feel the hips and the punches
and the crunches of value or just the
intensity of the situation which is
oftentimes a very ignored thing in an
action movie yeah reason to see number
four this is just the best written and
directed video game adaptation thus far
John and I feel pretty much the same
about this movie you might have seen our
earlier responses to it and we were
acting like oh this film is amazing I
was excited for the fact that this film
is a solid good action video game
adaptation yeah that's the main thing I
wanted from this movie if you look back
at my trailer review for the film I
don't feel this film needs to be the
greatest thing in the world I need it to
be good enough to open up a door for
better video game movies and I feel like
it has the potential to do that all I
really wanted was just a good entry I
didn't really care for an amazing film
this isn't like Wonder Woman in the
sense of I was emotionally moved its
captivation movie still but it's an
entertaining good one and well-written
one and well directed like artfully
executed for the most part yeah I think
it's structured well takes its time it
has a good pace about it it felt like
somebody cared about it and it felt like
they took their time in tuning the
elements like is it gonna melt your face
off no probably not but it is a solid
action movie among a bunch of other
action movies I've seen this year it
left a good impression on me and yeah
for the most part there was nothing that
was ever glaringly out of place or
glaringly flat to me
it´ll conceived or anything like that
while the direction might not be the
sharpest or the most nuanced or
inventive one thing that I really loved
about just the credits of this film
immediately following the actors are
pretty much crunch together are the
stunt performers you can tell there's a
lot of stuntmen in this movie there's
some use of CGI for sure especially in a
movie like this but there's plenty of
times where I'm like I'm really glad
they took the time to let stuntmen do
their job in this film yeah and and it
seems like a lot of this takes place in
real locations so it has a certain yeah
realism about just the whole affair
there's like CGI enhancements to be had
here or there but for the most part I
felt pretty grounded in what they were
and
working on the video game gets really
mystical with certain elements that are
featured in this movie and I think you
put it best you said going mystical I
mean it's half way for like a movie
adaptation yeah it's like they didn't go
full Indiana Jones about it but they
kind of split the difference and they
they achieve their own level and one
thing I want to say last thing is that
the movies not flashy a lot with its
cinematography but there are some great
cinematography moments especially that
scene that you see in the trailer where
the ships crashing and she jumps
overboard there's this wonderful shot
where she's underwater the Lightning is
flashing and you see the ship falling
she's just it's just it makes it cut
that's the kind of thing that makes it
tense yes those attention to details
yeah reasons not to see it's a little
predictable and cliche like we keep
saying this film is a solid good movie
we're not saying it's the most amazing
thing in the world but in terms of a
video game movie it's pretty damn it
gives me hope yeah exactly this film but
yeah not like Assassin's Creed where it
comes out we're like oh okay so with
territory like this when you kind of
have to play it a little bit safe in
certain areas yeah some stuff with the
characters does get a little cliche some
stuff does get predictable how I best
described it I think was there's no
scene in this movie I don't like but
there are some moments with in scenes I
don't really like yes certain reaction
moments things that I was like nah that
that's a little too cliche or even the
way the movie ends this is not a spoiler
for you guys at all it's a franchise
building movie so of course they're
gonna try to end it in a way where
you're gonna get a sequel they're
setting you up for a hot minute there I
thought they were just gonna wrap up
this story and end and I was like cool
nice but then they kind of shoehorn some
[ __ ] in there that I'm like I don't
really care for everyone some others
some cheesy stuff but overall it's about
the execution of that material and while
I think all the action scenes are really
well shot and really well done some of
them don't feel entirely necessary but
the reason I can forgive it is a it's a
video game movie and we haven't had
great ones be they're still shot well
like there's this bicycle chase early on
in the movie that's done really really
enjoy the sequence but ultimately the
like was entirely necessary for the
movie there's another on foot action
sequence and the first half of the movie
that you're like now wasn't really
necessary
it's still done well oh yeah yeah yeah
and and because of those things there
are times where maybe like 3/4 of the
way through I started to think okay you
know we're at such a point in the story
where I kind of know what we got to do
to get this wrapped up so it starts to
maybe drag a little bit or you start to
feel the time a bit I think some of the
unnecessary action moments did occur
because if they didn't have them
I feel like audiences who came in to see
an action movie based on Tomb Raider
would have been like where's all the
action I think it would have been cool
build-up to get the action just past the
midpoint of this movie that would have
been neat but for audiences like this
and you have to play it a little safe it
just makes sense to me that they would
throw in a couple of actions things that
ultimately necessary but still executed
in a great choreographed way reason not
to see number two this isn't the
monumental emotional video game film
achievement you might be hoping it is
this isn't gonna be that like we're here
to just tell you that we're really
highly recommending it because of the
fact that it's the first just solid good
video game adaptation film
yeah with not that many asterisks yes to
it you know we don't want to tell you
guys that like we were emotionally
captivated by this movie or that it's
necessarily groundbreaking like I think
it has set a bar granted not off very
hard bar to hit it set a bar that's a
good intro and you could see this bar
being up too you can see this bar being
beat but it's at least set a bar but if
you're going in for like a masterpiece
of a film something that's like what the
Dark Knight did for comic book movies or
for Wonder Woman did for the DC it's not
that film but if you're going in for
like finally a good video game movie
yeah one that proves that we're at least
capable now and and here is a good
example of how it might work and here's
some examples of how it could it's like
when you get like a solid good MCU film
it's like it's not like necessarily the
greatest emotional thing in the world
but it's good solid yeah yeah and I left
feeling like there's potential for these
kinds of movies in the future you know
it gives a step in the right direction
it's a step up so while it's not you
know 10 out of 10
and it's still a pretty enjoyable
popcorn movie subject to all the things
that those movies are but if you're down
with that kind of thing I think you'll
enjoy this Oh at all I guess John and I
would definitely say there are way more
reasons to see Tomb Raider then there
are not to sense you later if the
expectation factor for you has been low
you'll enjoy it even more yet if we made
it too high for you you might be a
little bit supported who knows I say
just go check it out for yourself enjoy
the ride alright guys well did you see
Tomb Raider what do you think of it or
what video game do you honestly think
can make the most solid movie or TV show
adaptation would love to hear your
thoughts on that put it in the comment
boxes below okay both anyway you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification Bell to get notified
every time one of our videos is up and
you can go ahead and check us out on
patreon thank you to everyone who's
joined our patreon so far we do
full-length Q&A is over their weekly
video responses as well as full-length
TV show reactions to plenty of TV shows
right now would love to have you and
also please check us out on viewer
reviews.com
much appreciate it